i don't think i'm super smart
but i know i'm smarter than you
this dude
i find his bomb
out by the trash cans where i empty the
trash he hid his bum in a weird like
hobbit bag
yeah like a hand knit like i wouldn't
notice his hand woven
eight century hobbit bag
that had a pan flute in it or some [ __ ]
but it wasn't it had a [ __ ] bong in
it this dude thinks he's so smart didn't
that happen oh yeah it happened um
can i uh can i tell you something i've
ever told you before
just just on that note just on that note
wait wait wait wait wait this is a live
crowd do i want to hear something i've
never heard before does anybody else
want to hear it
are you ready okay
i don't think i'm smart i know i'm smart
and i know you're stupid because you
found the decoy bomb
[Applause]
wait wait wait wait wait that makes no
sense
what does that mean did you ever even
like look at the bomb closely
no okay
it didn't work it was broken it was
cracked in three different sides there
was something stuck in the downstem you
couldn't hit it if you tried
that was that rhymed by the way i don't
know if anybody got that i was kind
um but so here's the thing i started i
did that because it was around the time
that i figured out he started snooping
he found a vape in my room and i got
ridiculed tobacco
which is fair but so i knew you were
snooping
and so i decided to plant something
somewhere
to where i knew you would find it and
then think you found everything and not
go look for the actual bong and the
actual stash that was just sitting in my
room for 10 years
[Applause]
but i know i'm smarter than you
thank you madison
yeah yeah he's wearing shorts on a date
don't
that is some [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah i've been waiting for a good time
this is mine this is my man right here
we're going to stick together you know
what i'm saying yeah exactly
that last line [ __ ] killed me
i don't think i'm smart but i know i'm
smarter than you he's like
really hit hard
24 day i'm living [ __ ] just to make it
through another 24.
foreign
[Music]
another day another dollar howler 7 pm
once i'm gonna break another bug